what if you don't have muscles to do
that
I love this part but he's like what if
you don't have muscles to do that and
then she's like all girls have the
muscles to do this my name is Rachel
tole ceman and I'm a professional pole
dancer
I've been pole dancing for probably
around eight years and I've competed
internationally and won a bunch of
prestigious titles and today I'm going
to be critiquing some iconic pole
dancing scenes in several movies
[Music]
okay so she's doing like a proper leg
back hook spin their underarm turn and
then it kind of cuts out and I noticed
we only see like the top half of their
body and we don't see what's going on
the bottom halves I think they make them
look more skilled in with the camera
angles that they choose that hand change
at the end was a little bit rocky with
the top hand she doesn't move through
the the twisty grip position and then
back naturally to a true grip position
like I think she leaves her hand
position and like in her wrist in the
same kind of formation and gets like
stuck there at the end and then has to
quickly change it so it's not very fluid
so there are several competitions out
there that are highly regulated like the
International pool Sports Federation
they send you a booklet full of tricks
and with the pictures of the tricks and
how many points are allotted to that
trick and how how you have to do it and
how long you have to hold that specific
position for that's that's like very
highly technical and maybe more sport
like whereas there are other
competitions that are more theatrical
and in nature so that requires you to
also be a good storyteller a good
actress a very good dancer as well like
a seven out of ten 7.5
[Music]
so definitely this is not Rihanna when
she does the whole kind of pass on the
pole she does a but that's called a
flying K and she's doing it in heels so
that's pretty pretty cool and then she
hooks her outside leg and then switches
to an inside lick hang and then kind of
reaches back that's called an Allegra
when she reaches behind the pole and
grabs the other leg and she's trying to
extend it even further so it also shows
like some flexibility there that's just
a fan kick so starting from the inside
leg to the outside leg it takes quite a
lot of work to host your leg up like
that that first move she does the flying
K and then to have the confidence to do
it on spin pole so poles can either be
fixed like static or they can be
spinning so that just a mechanism at the
bottom is released and the pole rotates
if you compete then you are expected to
do some some of your passes on static
pole and some of your other elements on
spin mainly with your doing any sort of
like backflips or things like that
you're going to be doing it on a fixed
pole so you'd be doing doing it on a
static one eight out of ten almost and
at an advanced level
just what an entrance like she's already
like approaching the stage and the pole
with such confidence so she goes into
like a basic spin that everybody learns
when they begin pull so it's a chair
spin and then she goes into like a back
hook body waves I mean she has this down
you know body rolls front hook spin
maybe fish hook spin I can't really tell
cuz they cut off her legs now it's like
very sit and coming down oh here's where
she inverts and that's really actually
quite great however if she does use her
outside leg to kind of host herself up
on the pole but I mean it's amazing what
she does
sliding down on the poles a little bit
like and I don't know like how she was
taught to come down but it looks very
nice actually so she's crossing her legs
almost like a hanging back however it's
sort of like a mix between a hang back
in a crucifix because she's keeping her
inside shoulder in front of the pole if
you can't come down from an invert in
like a forwards position in a controlled
way then it kind of looks kind of clunky
and that just requires more strength and
probably more time than she had to
prepare for this role but she actually
does invert so that's pretty cool I'm
like I'm pretty sure that that never
really happens that you have like that
amount of money yeah I think more people
would be doing it otherwise you know
[Music]
I really really like this scene because
it does actually kind of showcase
somebody like learning the very first
basic moves in pole how you can hook
your legs on the pole how can how can
you hook your ankle on the pole we sort
of have like a common vocabulary in in
the pole world with the names of tricks
some of them vary slightly from
depending on where you where you are you
can't carousel so I would call this a
chair spin to me carousel spin is when
your hips are actually facing the pole
the whole time in the spin where as the
chair spin you're spinning to the side
and you're you're basically parallel to
the pole as you go around and go into a
fairy City
stack cup well so weak I call this a
stag or double stag or Sun wheel as well
here's she does I would say that's a
layout not a tabletop but she's like
what if you don't have muscles to do
that and then she's like all girls have
the muscles to do this like it's just so
it's a lovely moment I think that they
showcase it here in this scene because
this is just like the typical journey
that everyone takes when they start
learning pole and you know she has these
probably seven-inch heels on so she's
already starting from an elevated point
on the floor so when she does do the two
climbs it looks like she's quite high
the viewer probably may come to
realization oh wow well actually this is
really like can be very technical and it
is a lot of hard work I would give a
nine out of ten
I think they're purposely doing a really
poor job of anything poll related
there's a competition called poll
theater and there's a comedic category
so you can enter and do something funny
like this and the purpose is to make
people laugh so they're trying to do
body waves here but they're doing like
these strange undulation and this is
like very poor example of like magic
like the hand position was always so
weird like why would anyone grab here I
would not advise licking the pole yeah
like a 1.5
[Music]
arching back I mean it's so common in
some of these clips it's just like
throwing yourself in a backbend like
okay this I was really impressed with
it's kind of like a box split that she's
sliding down into such as great
flexibility her back hook spin is really
nice and really fluid at the end where
she kind of kind of does like a little
arch up here's where she's doing an
invert and she comes into like almost
like a caterpillar climb like body wave
first you invert you go upside down you
go into what's called a crucifix so that
means your legs are above your head and
then you proceed to climb the pole
upside down and the reason why it's
called a caterpillar is because you're
kind of like if you go up the pole like
that it kind of looks like a little bit
of a wave like a little little worm or a
little caterpillar going up yeah she's
not moving with the climb she's just
holding with in between her knees and
there's not a lot going on but the the
elements that do happen I mean it's like
a seven
oops
[Music]
of a sassy kind of like hip movement
this is definitely I think along the
lines of more of a striptease burlesque
rather than anything pole there was sort
of a step around
[Music]
whole dance can be so many different
things it is I think it is an art form I
think it is a sport as well so one could
argue that this is just highlighting
kind of one aspect or one side of the
pole world the thing that comes to
people's mind the most when they
instantly think of pole if they don't if
they don't know otherwise maybe they
kind of assume that it is something that
belongs in the exotic world the art form
evolved from different forms coming from
India and China first so we have men on
poles doing acrobatic tricks and jumping
from pole to pole and so you have that
element but then of course the more
burlesque kind of side of pole evolved
in circuses and circus tents and ladies
you know dancing around the pole and
then you know doing a little burlesque
act and so that's kind of where that
side of pole originated she's very
believable as that kind of character but
but technically maybe like it too so
[Music]
for some reason reminds me a little bit
of Flashdance but it's not as nice you
know that's like that was so bad
sorry I don't mean any disrespect to the
actress but like basically looks like
she was trying to do a fireman spin
fireman spin is where you have the pole
I get between the thighs and your feet
are pointed towards your bum but it's
just like she's just like jumps onto the
pole first teaching people how to do
spins and basic things like no jumping
you're not allowed to just kind of jump
onto the pole and I'm very aggressive
striptease some sort of bikes around
spin no more leaking oh this is the
worst huh that one like little turn she
does with her leg out to the side looks
quite quite nice I think that's the best
the best move she does here I would give
her an A for effort but probably 4.5
[Music]
well it is highly choreographed first of
all kind of jazzy elements in it and
also um they're like Latin dance like
ballroom heels um on the poles I don't
know it just kind of reminds me of
something like Fosse I don't know why
yeah just the clacking of the heels and
then they're stopping and some acro
tricks okay so these guys now are doing
properly like hand Springs so that's
what that's what that move is called and
they're just hanging up there and like a
pike position or something and then they
do like a little middle split leap I
love it nice dramatic ending just with
some amazing like camerawork and camera
angles because she's not doing much
seven out of ten yeah
okay so she does do something quite
technical there and has like a proper
grip called like a bracket grip so the
outside arm is kind of a cross in the
bottom hand is low and she goes into a
move called cradle and opens up to that
split is called Jamila so yeah that's
actually pretty technical and I wonder
if it is her that did this or a dance
double or it's it's definitely a skill
that requires a bit of strength to do so
based off of that little little section
like that little move I would say maybe
six out of ten because it's not bad
[Music]
yeah I've never seen this the floor
actually this this combination of
striptease and singing a very kind of
emo song and then yeah there is the the
random pole in the background and she
takes a few walks around the pole
there's an underarm turn okay
the arms right now are kind of in like a
shoulder mount position so someone must
have I don't know maybe she thought that
up on her own but some maybe someone
kind of directed her to do that
it's a little bit of honey isn't it it
is really happy yeah I've never used
that word but yeah it's cheesy yeah I
would say cheesy I'm not gonna mark it
as low as um what was that date night
because you actually did like and
underarm turn
okay so we'll give it a 2 out of 10 and
this is like very poor example of like
[Music]